85 of people hate their jobs people
usually cite their income their commute
or their boss as a source of their
distress
you might also hear a lack of growth as
well as corporate culture to be
unbearable
but at the end of the day hating your
job is okay
because it's not the real problem and
here's why
[Music]
though it may seem like solving these
shortcomings will suddenly make your job
more bearable
this isn't exactly true at least not in
the long term
while people may pinpoint these
overlying issues as the source of the
misery
the real reason people don't like their
jobs is because they don't believe in
the purpose of their work
when people choose their career pathways
the top two things people consider
are the income potential as well as the
type of work
they usually paint a mental graph of the
relationship between a job stress level
versus the job's income and they
generally choose a career from this
graph that they think will have the most
favorable return
however this approach is flawed as
people usually end up choosing based on
the ease of the work
or the size of their paycheck as opposed
to impact of their work
though it might seem like having a low
stress job would be ideal
this is actually not true in fact
studies have found that high-ranking
government officials and military
leaders
who you would generally classify as
having more stress due to managing more
people
and having more responsibility actually
have lower levels of stress
as well as anxiety the thing is people
are instinctively looking to grow and
change and choosing a job that is
too easy leaves workers unengaged and
impartial to their work
moreover the leaders of the industrial
world also often hit a large portion of
their jobs
however they find their roles in society
quite fulfilling
this is because these leaders believe in
the larger missions of their work
and or their companies two great
examples of this are amazon and tesla
both jeff bezos and elon musk have
expressed hatred for their jobs from
time to time
jeff bezos has famously said that his
personal goal
is just to enjoy 50 of his work he talks
about how
no one is going to like every single
aspect of their jobs
as at the end of the day they are jobs
for him specifically
his number one pet peeve is being over
scheduled
as he is not a big fan of having plenty
of meetings per day
but even if he reaches his goal of
enjoying 50 of a day's work
this indicates that for every hour he
enjoys working
he has an hour that he doesn't if not
more
despite this jeff bezos is much more
than 50
satisfied with amazon this is because
though he may not enjoy the intricacies
of running a company day-to-day
he believes strongly in what amazon
accomplishes
you may love or hate amazon but the
truth is
amazon has revolutionized shopping and
shipping
and that is something jeff can get
behind similarly
elon musk doesn't always like his jobs
either two years ago
when tesla was going through production
hell he expressed this
no one should put this many hours into
work this is not good and people should
not work this hard i'm not
they should not do this this is very
painful
painful in what sense uh it's because my
ears my brain
and my heart at this point he was
sleeping on a couch in the factory and
working 20 plus hours per day
you really need no explanation as to why
he would find this quite unpleasant
though this particular instant was
temporary i'd be willing to bet that
most of the processes of developing
world-class batteries coding for
autonomous driving
and landing rockets are not the best of
experiences
however again the results are something
that elon can get behind
now i didn't choose these two examples
simply to illustrate how two leaders of
the tech world
don't necessarily enjoy their jobs more
importantly
a major difference between the two
companies is the satisfaction rates of
the employees
amazon consistently ranks as one of the
worst places in the world to work for
conversely spacex and tesla topped a
list of the top 30
most attractive places to work for for
engineers
now amazon is also quite high up on this
list
coming in at number nine however the
difference
is that the average employee at spacex
and tesla are engineers
while the average workers at amazon are
not engineers
but warehouse workers and delivery
drivers thus
this favorable view from engineers at
amazon is not an accurate view of the
perspective
of the average amazon employee two of
the biggest complaints from amazon
warehouse workers
are an extremely high workload as well
as being underpaid
in amazon's defense they did raise the
minimum wage for all amazon employees to
per hour nearly two years ago despite
this
the overall view of amazon is still
quite negative
as the general public still holds that
jeff bezos profits off of slave labor
what's ironic though is that these two
same shortcomings
apply to tesla and spacex yet that
hasn't affected the employee's
viewpoints
the average salary for a tesla engineer
is 88 000
while the average salary for a software
engineer at spacex is 105 000
i'm not saying these are bad salaries
but let's keep in mind that these
employees
are literally ai developers and rocket
scientists
not to mention they're some of the best
in the world
as such these guys could easily switch
over to google
where the median salary for all of their
employees is 246 000
or maybe they could go over to facebook
where the median is 240 000.
in essence there's no doubt that spacex
and tesla employees make good money
however they are vastly underpaid for
their skill sets
as they could easily move over to
another tech company
and not just make twenty or thirty
percent more but two to three times more
so it's definitely not the money that's
making these employees so happy
similarly the working conditions are not
much better either
elon musk has revealed that during
production hell
not just him but everyone at tesla was
working well in excess of 100 hours per
week
which is the same as 14 hours a day for
7 days a week
and i don't care how much you like
engineering or coding
you're not going to enjoy putting in
this many hours whatsoever
so it's not fat paychecks or passion for
engineering
that's getting these workers so
satisfied with their work
but rather it's their impact and that's
the key difference between workers
who like their jobs and workers who
don't
employees who like their jobs are
connected to the overall mission of the
company
or project while employees who don't
like their jobs
aren't neither amazon nor tesla
employees find their jobs to be super
pleasant
however the average amazon warehouse
worker doesn't care to work an extra
twenty percent
to get impulse purchases to their
customers two hours earlier
while the average tesla engineer is more
than willing to put in another fifty
percent
to accelerate the transition into
electric autonomous vehicles
and this same principle applies to all
industries
the average finance worker doesn't care
about making another half a percent in
returns for their already rich client
the average lawyer doesn't care about
using tax loopholes
to bail out another stingy client and
the average manager
doesn't care about squeezing out the
last 10 percent of work from their team
conversely teachers who love their jobs
don't actually enjoy
meetings planning or grading which is
the majority of their work
not to mention their major paychecks
however
they enjoy seeing their students grow
and evolve and
psychologists don't enjoy hearing about
people's problems all day
however they find meaning in helping
their patients achieve a better mental
state
and lead a happier life moving forward
and that's the main takeaway from this
video
eighty-five percent of people don't hate
their jobs because they're overworked
and
underpaid or any of the other popular
reasons
rather eighty-five percent of people are
simply not invested in the outcome
as a result when pursuing a career the
most important factors to ensure
satisfaction and fulfillment
are not how easy the job is or how much
you get paid
ideally you at least somewhat enjoy the
work itself
but over 40 years it's likely that
you'll find significant portions of your
work unpleasant
regardless of how passionate you are and
that's completely fine
as it's the purpose that makes you
satisfied not the work itself
but that's just what i think drop a like
if you guys agree
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one